The Adventures of Gilligan's Island.
Okay, little buddy, you just stay right behind your old pal the Skipper and everything's gonna be just fine.
And welcome to NEStalgia, a chronological exploration of every NES game released in North America.
I'm Mike. I'm Sean.
And I'm Joe.
Despite the name of the game being The Adventures of Gilligan's Island, today you'll be playing as the Skipper.
Also, despite the back of the box making it sound like it's talking to you as Gilligan.
And despite the whole show really revolving around the, I don't know, the hilarity of Gilligan.
Is Gilligan like that era's version of Steve Urkel?
I don't, I, I have never watched the show.
So I don't, have you guys watched the show?
I, when, oftentimes when we do episodes like this, where it's like a, a show from, well,
usually it's a show from the eighties or something, not the sixties or whatever.
But I'm always like, well, I actually haven't seen that.
I'm slack and I haven't seen this.
Uh, when I was in maybe like third to fifth grade, for some reason, I was obsessed with
Gilligan's Island.
I would, I would like have, I would have like sleepovers with my friends to watch Gilligan's
Island marathons.
Like that was, that was what we were doing in the nineties.
That was weird. Yeah. It was random.
Um, so I haven't watched it in a long time, but I was a big fan as a kid.
Wow. Well, I imagine it was on like Nick at night or something, right?
Yeah. There, it would be like in the summer, it'd be like every day of the week was a different
like rerun of some show marathon.
And one of the nights it was always Gilligan's Island.
Gilligan's Island also has one of the best theme songs for a TV show.
Um, although that, you know, Nick at night always chose the best.
Uh, I think, I feel like they chose the sitcoms based on their theme songs between, uh, cheers
and three's company.
Like speaking of those other shows, uh, you know, I'm, I have no doubt that Gilligan's
Island had reruns in the nineties and was still a relatively like popular show to catch on
TV. They weren't making new episodes obviously, but it is weird that it's coming to a predominantly
children's video game console where it's like, okay, what's next is, is a honeymooners
video game coming up.
Is it? I love Lucy video game coming up.
Uh, Gilligan's Island is a show from, uh, the late sixties.
So it is a little strange, uh, to suddenly get a video game for it.
Right? Yeah.
And it, a video game that like, as, as video games go, like of that, that are trying to create
the video game version of something that really doesn't need it.
I'll, uh, uh, like, uh, like three stooges.
Uh, this is probably the closest to just like the TV show that, that shit.
Because like, you know, in the three stooges game, it, it was like throwing like trivia at
you and just different like mini games.
Whereas this is, it's almost more naturalistic.
It, it's weird.
I'm not sure. Yeah.
It, it almost feels like you play through a few actual episodes of Gilligan's iOS.
Well, it wants you to think that, right?
It starts off stage one as not stage one, but episode one.
Right. They've got a banter system that always messes up.
Well, this is like a, um, the banter system is, uh, the using, it's working on the foundation
of a boy and his blob.
Right. Remember how like in that game things just talked, uh, you know, as you're playing the
game. Um, yeah.
So this is like what Gilligan and the skipper are doing throughout this game.
And if you think about it, since you don't control Gilligan, he's really just like the
blob in this game.
Yeah. Really.
And you, you, you, you have to manage him.
Like, and I, I'm, I'm trying to remember a boy and his blob.
I, you, you lose the blob sometimes, right?
You have to like find out ways to get him to where you are.
But the blob is essentially helpful.
Yes. That's true.
Right. Whereas Gilligan is pretty useless in this game.
Yeah. But was also pretty useless in the show.
So at least they're like identifying the characters correctly.
Yeah. That's what I was going to ask as you guys, as people that have seen Gilligan's Island,
like I watched a couple of clips and I, I couldn't really get, I couldn't really get
a handle of like, firstly, who Gilligan was for a second.
I thought that he was the skipper, but then also like, is he the straight man?
Is he, what is, what is Gilligan?
No, you asked if he was like Steve Urkel.
And I would say that he is only in the sense that he is like the, the comic core of the
show. But Urkel was a lot more competent.
Like Gilligan is like, he's the screw up, you know?
Oh wow. Okay.
And he, he often is like, you know, skipper hits him with his hat all the time because
he, cause he does something wrong or they're about to get off the island and Gilligan ruins
it in some way or something like that.
So he, he's, he's more, he's stupid.
He's a stupid character. Yeah. It's called Gilligan's Island actually.
Cause Gilligan won't let them off the island.
Yeah. And I was talking about, uh, how in like, you know, it's 1990 now and Gilligan's Island
maybe it was in reruns or whatever.
Uh, the last Gilligan spinoff thing to run on TV was actually Gilligan's Planet.
A, uh, it aired for a few months on a CBS.
It was a, a Saturday morning cartoon series, uh, spinoff of, um, Gilligan's Island.
There was many spinoffs of Gilligan's Island, the new adventures of Gilligan, but Gilligan's
planet, uh, is where they ended off.
And you'll understand that, uh, obviously the video game here would make no reference
of something that got one season, 13 episodes and aired from just September 18th to December
11th of 1982.
This was 1982.
That was 1982.
That's the, but that's the most recent representation they had in media, you know?
So that came and went and probably killed all hopes of Gilligan's universe, uh, being a
thing. And so instead they went back to basics here with the adventures of Gilligan's Island.
Uh, however, I questioned the title, the adventures of Gilligan's Island.
Cause the game doesn't start up like that.
The game just on the title menu just says Gilligan's Island.
Right. I noticed that too.
But the box says the adventures of Gilligan's Island.
And I guess since it's going for the show format, calling it Gilligan's Island does make more
sense. Right.
I think that they would, if they wanted it to sound like the show, because people like
the show, you got to put that on the box.
You can put whatever you want in the title.
The box is what people are going to look at to buy it.
I think the most accurate name for this game would have been Gilligan's Island guidance.
Yes. Yeah.
Cause these aren't a sanctioned episodes.
They're not canon, uh, to the series.
The, the main trope of the show of course is that, uh, or I shouldn't say main trope, but
like the most recognized fact about the show now in hindsight is all of these celebrity
or cameo appearances throughout the, uh, three seasons.
Those people always left the island and it was like, well, where did they go?
Like, why didn't the cast of Gilligan's Island, the castaways also just leave with them?
And if the professor is so smart, why can't he figure out how to get off?
Like they went on a, they went on like a three hour boat tour.
They're not that far away from civilization.
It's not like lost where they were in a plane, you know, and they, and they crash landed on
an Island there.
They could probably start working on just tying together a couple logs and sailing back.
I mean, they do. Yeah.
Again, just from the little bits of the show that I watched, like they've got, they've got
some pretty good, like construction hands.
Like that wasn't pretty solid looking structures.
Uh, so if you just like removed the roof and the walls and just put them all like down flat,
like that's, that's a good raft right there.
You got a stew going.
Yeah. And you know, the, the Island also often is like revealed to have like traces of civilization
on it. Like they dig up the Dharma, like telephone wires at one point.
They're like, Oh my God, like we can, we can make a phone call.
If we can hook up a telephone or the telephone wires.
And there's like, yeah, a bunch of different things that they're always finding like, you
know, World War two paraphernalia on it or whatever.
Yeah. A world war two bong.
Yeah. So the game has four levels or episodes.
And, uh, in each of these episodes, it always, um, it always starts with that.
The goal is to locate all the crew members, um, before time runs out and to do so, everybody
else is working on something or has a task at hand and you are just playing as the skipper
with Gilligan alongside you.
You have to, uh, navigate your way through the Island, collect the important items and,
um, find, um, a particular character to give you a hint on what to do next.
You mentioned the, uh, we'll call it the dialogue banter system between skipper and Gilligan.
Does that, is that just a comedic thing where, you know, Gilligan will just, uh, say, I've
got a really bad feeling about this over and over again, or does that amount to some form
of gameplay as well?
Is it just there for flavor?
There's information. Or did you find any use?
Uh, it really only, so like when you're speaking to other characters, like they will react differently
whether Gilligan is with you or not, uh, because he's supposed to be with you.
Um, and if you do get separated, then the banter is just like, hey, skipper, where the hell are
you? And stuff.
So it's at least like also, uh, used as a little bit of like an information system of like, hey,
you are doing things wrong.
Yeah. I feel like there were also, and I can't think of an example now, but weren't there also
a couple of times, a couple of instances where it'll say something to the effect of like,
oh no, we're in this spot.
We have to do this.
Or, you know, like give you like a hint on the situation too.
Yeah. And it'll let you know if you're running low on time.
Yeah. Oh, right.
Right. And it also does kind of become accidentally funny.
Uh, like sometimes you'll be fighting, uh, the enemy animals, snakes or what, you know,
like whatever you run into in a particular scene, you'll be fighting them, get knocked
over by one and Gilligan will just chime in with like, isn't this scenery beautiful?
And it's like, meanwhile, skippers like knocked on his ass.
Like, and it's like accidentally funny because the game obviously is just playing this dialogue
at random. Um, but, um, I dunno, I, I actually thought it was a, a rather, uh, clever move for a sitcom,
which all, you know, lives and dies by, uh, the dialogue between characters to have this
system between its two most famous characters.
Uh, whether it could have been, uh, more tied to the gameplay, I think, uh, they relied
more on the Gilligan NPC to tie more into the gameplay because, uh, Gilligan will often do
things that, or go to places where you didn't want him to go.
Since you have no control over him, he will just fall into pits or climb up trees or, um,
you know, uh, walk in the opposite direction.
And there's not really much you can do about that other than go track them down.
And, uh, that really adds most of where the time limit, um, you know, uh, fear comes into
play. Like, I'm sure they give you enough time if you were just skipper without Gilligan, but
having to constantly like track down Gilligan and reconnect with him, uh, really adds to
the whole, like, well, there goes two minutes.
Don't you love games long?
Uh, like, well, what's the word I'm looking for?
Escort missions.
Yeah. Uh, yeah.
And that's really kind of like what this is, except for thankfully it doesn't seem like
Gilligan himself has like a health bar or can die.
Oh yeah. No, he's totally fine.
It's you who's in trouble.
He just slows you down and you have to like wait for him before like you, there's a very
specific amount of pixels away that Gilligan can be, uh, before you walk over to the next
screen. Otherwise he just like forgets where he is and like just stays there and you have to
go back and get him.
And yeah, there's, well, even though it's not the same kind of frustration that a typical
escort mission from the early two thousands would have, uh, there's still escort mission
frustrations. And if he would just actually be an escort mission in the sense of if he would just stay
by your side, uh, granted you'd have a little more of a boring game and a unnecessary Gilligan,
but that's, that's kind of like what usually happens when you're trying to like help a princess
get across a dangerous area is they, they mostly just stay out of harm's way and follow
you along a path that you're clearing before they take too much damage.
Gilligan is really just free to roam whatever parts of the screen you leave accessible.
And Skipper doesn't really have a lot in terms of, uh, combat abilities.
He can really only punch and use the club.
Joe, would you say that's about, uh, accurate for the show as well?
He really just, it's been, it's been a long time, but I don't remember a club ever being
used by the Skipper.
I thought he should have been using his hat because that's how he hit Gilligan.
Cause they had an abusive relationship, but yeah, the hat would have been, the hat would
have been great. Well, you can't defend yourself against apparently indigenous people.
Right. With the hat, which is something I think we should talk about.
Yeah. Maybe, maybe a little problematic at this point.
Is our headhunters, are those from the show?
That's from the show.
Headhunters is how they're referred to.
So who are they?
Well, I don't know what-
Yeah, they're indigenous to this island.
This World War II paraphernalia island.
This seems a little weird.
I saw in the manual them referred to as headhunters,
and I was like, hold up, hold up.
Is that what they were called in the show?
And yes, they are the headhunter tribe.
And they're the biggest threat in the Gilligan universe.
See, I'm trying to remember,
because I do remember a lot of episodes
where they would be at play.
But were they on the same island,
or were they on a neighboring island
that sometimes they would visit?
They would send raiding war parties?
Yeah, there would be some really dark episodes
where they would just be really violent.
Because of the possible limited number of islands in the region,
it is very likely several of the natives
encountered by the castaways come from common islands.
Ah, common islands.
Islands that, you know, neighbor the island that they're on,
but aren't close to civilization either.
I read this on the wiki, yes.
Okay, so I guess what we're saying is the club is non-canon.
The club is non-canon.
I don't remember the club.
And I'll say, I was playing this game,
I was only playing the first episode at first,
and I was also watching a video I scrubbed ahead
and just saw this part where the skipper is just fighting
these indigenous people with a club,
and I'm like, okay, what's going on here?
Like, what is this?
This seems like, you know,
I don't want to be caught playing this game now.
Yeah. The first episode is totally fine,
because those people aren't in the game.
The only, like, thing that you hit with a club
is, like, a big monkey.
So those are fair game.
But, like, later, it just, you know,
it gets a little icky. Yeah, but they have clubs too.
True. Yes, they are armed.
Right. So it's, you know,
I didn't get to this point in the game
to see who initiated this fight.
Well, you don't just fight them.
You know, you also fight a lot of wild animals,
and who could forget that episode
where the skipper goes up toe-to-toe
with a grizzly bear?
Yes. Yeah, right, right.
But they saved the best for last,
because the final boss in the game is a skeleton,
which just only seems right, right?
And you would think, like, okay,
when I say skeleton, did you guys see it?
Did you see the skeleton that you fight?
Oh, no. I couldn't.
It's actually, like, one of those, like,
spooktober doot-doot skeleton.
Like, it's not even, like,
it's not even an intimidating skeleton or whatever.
It's just literally a human,
anatomically correct skeleton
that hits you with its own,
you know, what is that?
Like a femur?
The femur, yeah.
It hits you with the femur,
and you hit back with the club,
and Gilligan just won't shut the hell up
during the whole fight.
And it doesn't happen in, like,
a special cave or anything.
It just happens out on the island,
just, like, in the screen that was in
all the other stages, too.
And it just feels very, like,
is this the best they had for the end?
Like, shouldn't the headhunters have at least
been, like, the ending battle?
Like, that's a whole tribe of people.
Now it just turns out all you have to do
is take on a skeleton?
So, you're bringing,
you, like, mentioning this,
we're talking about sort of the things
that you might fight,
and how kind of out of left field
the ending is. I think this is a great point to mention,
like, what else is in this game?
It's just navigating mazes,
for the most part,
and collecting key items.
And when you're not fighting, like,
complete, like, non-sequitur enemies
or wild hogs that are running back and forth,
like, that's really it.
It's a maze runner game.
Yeah, and, like, even the,
when you are, like, fighting these enemies,
it's not great with hit detection
or with, like, the feel of swinging the club
or whatever. Like, it's, it's, uh...
Even just navigating. Like, it's not a welcome distraction.
Yeah. Because it's very frustrating.
Like, if you want to talk about hit detection,
like, just jumping over obstacles
could make you just fall on your butt.
Right. And that hurts you.
Yeah, a lot of things hurt you,
so thankfully there are bananas everywhere
for you to replenish your health,
which I guess is the closest that the game gets
to some kind of, um,
island resource management simulator
where you have to make sure you have enough bananas.
Yeah, but you know what I mean, right?
Like, they're on an island,
like, there should be some kind of,
um, you know,
hardcore Fallout New Vegas style rules
of, like, make sure you eat every so often.
Yeah, make this like a survival game.
Yeah, they need to sleep every now and again.
You have to, you know,
there's a vitamin C meter
to make sure that you don't get scurvy.
The biggest weakness of the game
is also, uh,
the fact that the other core characters
of Gilligan's Island
are relegated to just, like,
people you find to help you move along in the quest.
I'm fine with, like, the gang not all starting together
and them helping relay clues,
but shouldn't you have, like,
unlocked the other characters one at a time
and then also been able to play as them
via some other skill
that was, like, non-combat related?
So the professor has, like,
some really cool tech thing
that you can use to now get to other parts of the island
and, uh, Marianne uses her looks
in one way or another.
I don't know, like, what would the other one's superpowers even be, I guess?
But I had something good with the professor
and I thought, like,
it would have been great
to, other than just bumping into them
and just being like, oh, cool, you should go here next, like,
if they had more purpose.
I think what, yeah.
I think if it was a whole, like,
base building simulator
and you could make your own Gilligan's Island
and there'd be, like, a tech tree
that the professor could work through,
uh, and it's sort of, like,
open world Gilligan's Island,
I think that'd be great.
Yeah, or, or even, like,
you know, give you,
let you, you pick up these characters
as you go and they each have different abilities.
Gilligan's always a hindrance
and then, like, the professor can, yeah,
can build something for you
when you reach certain spots. So it's almost like a Metroidvania.
Like, okay, now you have Marianne,
now you're able to, you know,
get past this obstacle.
The weirdest part of this game
for me might be related to the plot
that has nothing to do
with the skeletons, but the fact that the,
the game is
not about trying to get off the island,
like, the core idea of the show
and instead in the,
in this game
we're not thinking about that at all.
Well, you don't wanna,
I mean, like, as the viewer
you don't want them to get off the island,
you know, like. Is that true?
I feel like I did want them
to get off the island. But that means the show ends.
No, the show didn't end
when they got off the island
and lost. Well, that's,
a spoiler.
Yeah. Well, they still had
a bunch of Flash Sideways
to get through,
so, I don't think it's
that bad of a spoiler.
Okay. Joe, you're just a fan
of island things in general.
Any other, like,
island things they could've done here?
Island boys? Island things?
Yeah, they could've, they could've,
every three days,
gone to tribal council
and voted one of them
off the island.
Has that ever been done
on Survivor? Or have they ever done,
like, a Gilligan's Island,
like, reference or challenge?
No, it's been 20 years.
I don't think so.
I mean, I've seen most of the seasons.
None of the cast
of Gilligan's Island
ever, like, showed up?
Yeah, no. I mean,
I'm sure, I'm sure a contestant
has mentioned Gilligan's Island
and has said, like, I'm the skipper
or whatever. But I don't remember
production ever leaning
into any Gilligan's Island
themed things. That's wild
because both of them are CBS.
Gilligan's Island is CBS?
Yes. I mean, I've actually completely
ruined any opportunity
for cross-promotion.
Yeah. Oh, wait,
I might be wrong. No, I'm right.
Never mind. See how fast I can be right?
Just kidding, I'm wrong.
No, no. Yeah,
maybe my,
maybe I don't just,
it's not island things
that I love, maybe I just love CBS shows.
So do we know about
any of these other Gilligan's Island things?
So there was Gilligan's Island,
then there was
The New Adventures of Gilligan,
not on the island,
but on the, well, not,
The New Adventures of Gilligan,
not The New Adventures
of Gilligan's Island
is where I'm getting at. But,
um, Was that like also
on an island? It's a Saturday morning
cartoon, and yeah,
it's, the whole thing is
on the island still.
Okay,
so it's just a different,
okay, just a cartoon version of it.
Yeah, and then in 78,
the made-for-TV,
uh, film,
Rescue, from Gilligan's Island.
Did they, did they get off?
Uh, I never saw it,
but I think I know,
spoiler alert, I think that they do
get off the island,
and they go back home
and everything, and then somehow
at the end of the film they end up back
on the island. That's,
that's a horror movie.
Yeah. So that leads to
the 1979,
the 1989 follow-up movie,
The Castaways, on Gilligan's Island.
Hmm, and maybe that's the movie
I'm talking about. I know one of the movies
had them escape
and then get back.
Yeah, so after,
after all that,
right, so you have the,
the original run,
the cartoon, two movies,
where do you go from there?
Well, space. NES.
The Harlem Globetrotters
on Gilligan's Island.
A 1981 TV film
in which the Harlem Globetrotters
visit Gilligan's Island.
Oh, they made it a movie.
Yeah, but they visit,
too. It's like, what do you mean?
Take them with you.
And this is with, well,
so I know, all right,
in the episode, there was always
a reason,
a way, in probably like a silly,
stupid way, but like a reason
that the guests
got off the island
and did not save
the castaways.
But you can't remember
not a one, can you?
I can't remember one,
no, but I do remember
it wasn't just like, all right,
we're leaving now, good luck on getting
off the island. You know,
there was always like,
oh, something, they get like blown away
by a tornado or something,
I don't know. They get amnesia
or something on their way out.
Amnesia. And the earlier mentioned
Gilligan's Planet
is a,
it's another animated cartoon
where the professor,
rather than building a raft
and getting off the island,
decides to go full steam ahead
on interplanetary travel
and gets everybody
on a spaceship
to which,
of course, as soon as they take off,
they crash land
on an unknown planet
that is able to support
human life and now they're stuck
on an entire planet.
Wow. Yep.
I might have to watch this.
Sean, you said open world game
earlier for Gilligan's Island
and I like the idea of that
but then you got me thinking
about Gilligan's Planet,
something I never thought about
before this morning
and now I'm like,
when is the first
open planet game coming?
You mean,
like No Man's Sky?
Yeah, I guess so,
right? Like, are those planets big enough?
Yes. So those planets,
some of them, are the size of Earth?
I think so.
I mean, they're not like,
yeah, I think they are like
huge planet size
like things,
it's just that there's
almost no
variation so,
like, once you see
one square kilometer,
you've seen
all of them. I mean,
that part is true
but when I was playing it,
I was looking it up
and I guess like the average planet there
like would take you
like eight hours
to walk the perimeter
or something like that.
Like, still something absurd
that you wouldn't do
but like not,
not actually.
so they're little moonlets then.
Got it. Because I think I want
this Gilligan's Island game
to be the first open planet game
where it's a little bit
like Final Fantasy 7
where first you're just
trapped on Gilligan's Island
or Midgar for like,
you know, all of disc one
and then all of a sudden
they like, the professor finally
invents the raft
and it's like,
oh no, you can go everywhere
on earth in this game actually.
Like, now you're free to,
you have to be Gilligan
unfortunately. Can you go to New York City?
Yeah, you could just go to New York City,
you could go to Hong Kong,
you can get a job.
It's like, it's all there
but like, under the guise
of Gilligan's Island.
Unfortunately, we can't vote
based on that pitch.
We have to vote
based on the NES game
that we played and so we will do that now
on the Essential Games list.
Oftentimes in this game,
you will just be
trudging through
either like,
what I imagine is
some version of quicksand
or mud
or something
and you'll be moving very slow
and it's during those moments
where you have to
trudge along
and you can continue
to move forward.
There's no enemies
in your way. The time limit
is ticking down
but you're moving
at a pretty steady pace
but you just kind of slowed down
the overall game. It's during those moments
where you're just holding left
or right on the D-pad
and trudging along
that you really start
to question was it ever a good idea
to play every NES game
released in chronological order?
because I don't think
I would have ever imagined
a Gilligan's Island game
on NES. Just that idea, right?
Like I was joking about Honeymooners
and I Love Lucy but really
like now
the floodgates are open.
I believe that later on
in this catalog we will get a Gunsmoke.
We did get Gun.Smoke.
Gun.Smoke. Yeah, we did get
Gun.Smoke. So maybe that was a bad example.
We'll get Bonanza.
We'll get Cheers,
the video game.
We'll get Full House
tournament simulator.
It'll all be there.
I would love
a Full House tournament game.
And just like
for what it's worth like obviously
it's a no but it's not even like
it's not even the worst game
I've played. So it's like
it sounds like
I really beat up this game.
It's not the worst game I've played.
It's just a it's a huge why for me.
I can't imagine
that the core audience
of people that owned
in NES at the time
were like
finally a Gilligan's Island game
right? Was this supposed to be
like the game that got dad
onto the system?
Like your dad was against video games
because they're
you know they're
you're playing Robocop
and stuff like that
and now finally
you can play
Gilligan's Island
go back to
his childhood
and everything. I don't know
who this game was for.
It's not
so bad
that it's good. It's not
not so bad
that it's bad though.
It's just kind of
another game in the library
and so that's why
I'm just kind of
meandering my thoughts here
because it's just
it's just there.
It's just now a game
that I can say I've played.
Sean? Yeah.
Um I
this is one of
our weirder episodes
because we really couldn't
be bothered to talk about
this game very much.
Uh we'd rather
sort of
like I guess
uh just sort of
visualize Break down the show.
Yeah. Visualize
what Gilligan's Island
actually is.
Only one of us
has really watched it.
Uh uh
but I mean
it like Mike said
it's kind of
just just strange
that the game even exists
but then if you go back
and you like you look at the main
the first thing
that you see when you book the game up
and you see that this was made by
Bandai
or at least
published by them
so this is
this isn't like a
Data East
or an LJN
which are who are kind of just like
fumbling through life
like this is a company that
to some extent
knows what it's doing
and it made the decision
to finance this
and
I don't understand it
um
I guess just
befuddlement is
my
default
thought
uh
about this game
yeah it's not it's not essential
but I didn't
really I didn't hate it
as much nearly as much
as most games not most games
uh
as many games
so
yeah how about you
Joe uh
I'm surprised
by the
amount that we were
able to talk about
this game and
I honestly
think that we inadvertently
made this game
seem like there's a lot
more to it than there is
I mean
you pick up this game
for five minutes
and you understand this game
it's very basic
there's not much to it
you're just collecting things
Gilligan's
gets lost sometimes you have terrible
hitboxes terrible
controls
uh
and
as much as it breaks my heart
because I was a big fan of
Gilligan's Island this is a bad game
it's a bad game
all right so essential
yeah thank you
um two no's
one essential vote
uh you heard it here
uh
Sean you are correct
Bandai published it
Human Entertainment
developed the game
and that'll never get weird
to say yeah that is
suspicious
yeah
Human Entertainment
made a game
uh about Gilligan's
Island that should have
really been about Gilligan's
Planet next week
we have Battle Chess
couple of other
um bigger beats
coming up a game called
Crystalis I've heard a lot of
talk about that one
so I'll be playing that
for the first time is that a first for you guys
as well uh huh
sure is
all right uh
and then a couple weeks
from now you might have heard of this game
it's called Final Fantasy
any interest
I've never heard of it
I think it's pronounced
Final Fantasy
okay good call
um
some more
uh IP stuff
we'll be doing uh
Mad Max
um
I think those
yeah those are the ones
based on
um the
what's his face
the guy we can't talk about
anymore Mel Gibson
could be anyone a lot of people
right um
Joe can finally talk about
Pictionary I know you've been waiting
for that one I talk about it a lot
because I remember when we first did that episode
what about
um
I got that reference
thank you
um
are we close to
being able
to play
Halo uh
Halo is actually
just a millennium away
so we will get to it
okay cool
crank crank crank